the afrofuture center of perspective is
intersectional
and rejects binaries for a long while
now futures thinking
and afrofuturism haven't really
addressed
the plight of trans black bodies of
queer people
and their tradition in our tradition and
it wasn't until recently that the
national lgbtq task force
apologized to trans people for ignoring
them
and we have in the past you know in the
past several years
uh trans people who are being killed are
alarming weight and they're black trans
people
and so we want to make it clear that
black trans lives matter
that black queer people matter
i'm a product of multiple identities
growing up in los angeles
and even in los angeles as as black and
jewish
and queer and uh you know i was um
i had to uh navigate numerous types of
of identities
and i just remember this point in 1983
where i was in class with my english
teacher at fairfax high school in los
angeles and he begins the class
proclaiming you're all homosexual
we looked at each other kind of scared
initially shocked wondering
how did he know that about us
his point and you know it's not a new
one but queerness and most everything
else is on a spectrum
we are all queer and partake in
queerness
and queer time and i think it's an
important point to understand
how time can get out of its linear
construction
that we can talk actually talk about
what queer time might mean
see the black experience shapes our
lives afo queerness is part of our dna
part of that is really starting with the
birth of our species
you know 150 000 years or so ago
where we didn't have terms like queer or
homosexual or homophobia
and what life could have been like there
and to kind of
imagine it at the birth of our human
species
we had queerness weaved within it if we
look to indigenous tribes
they have a a space for gender fluidity
a third gender gender fluid pathways
that they celebrate people who are
gender fluid in native american tribes
and in aboriginal tribes are shamans
they're healers
they're future visionaries you know this
is really excellent
statuette of the first people having sex
that was ever discovered they're just
wrapped around each other and you can't
tell
what their gender is and i think that
really encapsulates
afroqueer and queer time
we can trace afroqueerness in egypt
there's also a tale of two manicurists
for the
pharaoh and when they rediscovered their
tomb
it shows them with their noses together
and mouths almost nearly together and
that's a sure sign that they were a
couple
because usually it was of opposite sexes
but it chose them together and they were
revered
and it wasn't a problem or as the clone
as the colonists arrived to the african
continent
and tried to make tribes shamed for
their fluid gender pathways and so
and we're still struggling with it right
there's this you know big
a big sort of uh eurocentric
christianity
abounded in africa that doesn't
recognize lgbtq rights
so i want to sort of come back to kind
of pre-colonial times
this existence and uh and there's you
know really great activists in africa
working
in the african nations working on this
too uh
to really bring queer futures and black
lives to the forefront and
making that connection and keep making
that connection
you know a great collaborator of mine
naija whitson at uc riverside
she's working on this great essay called
superfluid super black
and they flirt claim in this fantastic
quote i am
a black queer trans non-bearing artist
flowing fluently like the memory of my
super fluid slipping ancestors and
transistors
as my elder iaf fuyakati often reminds
me
if we are then someone else in our line
was
we are not the first and so that's
really important
because if you think about it in what
w.b du bois talks about double
consciousness they have a heightened
consciousness
they're able to see the fluid inter
intersections of identities that they're
living with on a daily basis
to guide their tribe and so i think you
know 150 000 years ago this must be
queer time this is queer time they
didn't have the terms for it
but i feel like it's time to really
acknowledge within the black tradition
that queerness has existed there's this
great documentary film artist
leo herrera who completed this project
called the father's project if they
lived
and he creates a series of four
documentary fictional
film documentaries about what it would
have happened
if the leaders during the aids epidemic
had lived
and we can't really imagine this creates
a queer future world
where the queer colonies have flourished
and he talks about the political
influence of these queer colonies
on the rest of the u.s and that the
queer colonies are becoming their own
autonomous regions
which i love as well too and so through
a series of four films
he leads us through these fantastic
images
that and you know finally also evokes
one of the uh leaders of app depp who's
running for president
in 2020. and uh so
these these types of things really
inspire me
to proclaim queer time continues with us
so i also aim to clear the categories of
forecasting future studies and foresight
as they are practiced
it comes from a long tradition of
african culture
that really didn't see race and class in
the same way that we do
it recognizes the interconnectedness of
all things
into which is bound to for
interconnectedness
it gives you a wider aperture on the
future where so many
corporations and organizations and
government agencies have tried to see
the future through a straw
seeing it through black perspectives
opens it up so you can see
signals and black signals and
afrofeature types happening on the
streets in front of you